hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game from round seven of
the Phaedo World Team Championship its
Kazakhstan versus Iran on board for we
have a leader as a ferocious board for
for Kazakhstan better kostenko and
yesterday we've seen a very nice game by
ali reza philosopher he well defeated in
in a marvelous fashion jones Pillman of
england brought his king all the way to
h3 which was a phenomenal game i'm sure
you're gonna enjoy this one as well but
before we check out the game david Lada
comes through for you once again so here
we here we have it another exquisite
photo of Alexander Stinson
I mean Greece shook there you have it
just you know looking legend there is
always nothing out of the ordinary in
this photo so let's just enjoy it for a
few seconds before we you know get get
into the game
there you have it I do hope you enjoyed
that now let's check it out ali reza has
the white pieces and he opens with E 4
we have e 6 d4 and d5 and I'm not just
showing this game because the French
defense was played I know you're gonna
say that Knight c3 with Knight to f6 the
classical variation of the French 'if
I've advancing the pawn define its
variation night every d7 and now as
black is prepared to push c5 white once
the you know improve the control in the
center so he goes f4 black continues
with his plan we have c5 just a nice
principled movie don't wanna attack the
central wheel with a nice flank pawn
Knight to f3 developing and also
defending in the center and not nice to
see six and here our blacks plan is to
play Queen to b6 to put further pressure
against the d4 pawn and then after black
captures once let's say seek after Sun
before then the bishop will also be
developed the c5 basically blacks entire
plan here is is going for this d4 square
Bishop to e3 by white now increasing the
pressure here we have a six and now
Queen to d2 with
b5 and here Bishop to d3 just developing
we have Queen to b6 this is still all
standard theory of this line and now
Queen to f2 the Queen now also joins in
to defend the d4 pawn and out black
finally captures we have C captures
Knight captures Knight captures Bishop
captures the queen is under attack and
now comes Bishop to c5 Bishop captures
here you could capture with the Queen or
would the knight Knight captures on c5
is played and here b4 and this position
has been reached a few times in a few
games Knight to a4 was played but the
Knights to a4 isn't all that impressive
because after Knight captures okay you
can capture an f2 King captures but it's
not a problem I mean you haven't ruined
the Kings position or anything you just
improve that King already move the white
rooks are connected and after black
captures here the a pawn is doubled so
not something you wanna well show your
friends you know so after this b4 move
we have Knight captures on d3 and now
after C captures on d3 it's move 15 we
have a completely new game now and d4
it's it's a very interesting position
because if you look at that white has a
knight black has a light square bishop
and this light square bishop isn't all
that impressive all of blacks pawns are
on light squares so let's say you trade
off the pieces you know you trade the
trade of the Queen straight of the rooks
and then black is left with this light
square bishop and if all of the blacks
pawns are fixed on light squares it's
gonna be a huge problem because this is
gonna be a terrible Bishop you can
imagine white can just go let's say 92
Knight d4 Knights the seif Knight to b3
then going Knight c5 and the c5 is a
nice dark square it will be an excellent
outpost for the night you will not be
able to move it from there also maybe in
the future even d6 will be available for
white tonight so definitely the knight
has an advantage over the bishop here so
black doesn't want to allow whites to
further push d4 here but could go for
Queen captures but like we already
mentioned it's not gonna be not gonna be
an anything good for black you could go
Bishop d7 maybe try to push a 5 button
white is just faster a4 immediately King
b7 out even a 5 and d4 is coming and
once you take control of the C file
you're just gonna bring the King into
the center and Riemann over your knight
over to the dark squares it will just be
a much better position for white so here
after C capture some d3 black decides to
play d4
somewhat making it easy for the white
knight to make his way over to c5 or d6
but you know at least it this way
Bishop the b7 can be played which is
played after castles and castles with
Bishop to d7 and now at least okay you
allowed the White Knight some excellent
squares here but you've also taken
control of this very important diagonal
so a fair trade-off I'm most likely the
best idea for black white alga Reza
mmediately goes for this beautiful dark
outpost and creates this monster night
here and now III don't think kostenko
was ever afraid that Knight captures the
bishop would even be an option because
this is just a beautiful night but still
rush up to d5 you don't want to allow
the tension to be in White's favor for
example if you have to calculate
something then you'll always have to
calculate he plays that I played that
and then he captures my bishop or he
takes that I do that he does that I do
this and then he captures my bishop
so you'll constantly have to keep an eye
on it this way just put it on a nice
central square you know it aims both
ways so it's a it's an excellent Bishop
and you don't have to worry about Knight
captures ever it's okay now white it
doesn't want to waste time so
immediately f5 f6 is a threat where he
was completely weakened the King side
black does not have a dark square Bishop
so it would be some serious dark square
weaknesses we need to Queen h6 a
possibility so what does the black does
have to capture with it captures on f5
and now well you could capture with the
Queen then f6 is somewhat problematic
you can't capture because the knight
would be hanging and also once the black
captures your Queen will be somewhat
exposed so here after it captures on a5
with Knight captures on a5 now black
cannot waste time with any silly pawn
moves because 97 check picks up the
Bishop on d5 so look after I ate now
attacking this point and now rook 81
bringing the last rook into the game
also defending the e5 pawn and black
goes to Queen to g6 and now black also
does have some threats you can see that
the g2 point is being pressured our
white constantly has to keep an eye on
this so first look to e2 you could go
for a knight characters on d4 but then
you also give a
the D 3 point you don't want to allow
black too much activity so first look to
e 2 just keep that night on f5 it's an
excellent piece you don't want to move
it to allow Queen captures on d3 and
also now that the rook is on e to the
Queen can move as the rook will also be
protecting the G to pawn we have rook a
to d8 black also develops his last
undeveloped rook and now comes Queen
captures on d4 it's a really interesting
move because well perhaps black thought
that white couldn't capture the pawn if
rook a to the 8th it's very interesting
your foot captures you know there's
always this idea of what happens if
Bishop captures on g2 now your queen is
just under attack and you know all sorts
of discoveries are being threatened here
but it's not actually a problem because
of 97 check and now if you capture the
night just check Roky 8 Queen captures
will be mate and if not if you know you
just want to move the King wherever
you're going if it or King to h8 Knight
will capture Queen with check so you're
you're gonna be completely lost here
captures with check you have to react to
this and then just Queen moves with
check and you just pick up the bishop
you are up a whole Queen so not a
problem here it is possible to capture
the d4 pawn and but black now goes f6 he
wants the he wants to create some
breathing room for the King and also
take care of this pawn in the center but
perhaps better what better was h6 wood
f6 the the King becomes a bit too
exposed but ok f6 was played and now we
have Queen b6 and Queen to b6 is an
excellent attacking move I you do see
the threat for example if black doesn't
react to this if black does something
silly let's say black goes h5 maybe he
wants to go crazy with h4 h 3 then just
rook captures will be sufficient for 4
whites to win the game after rook
captures 97 Czech picks up the Queen but
even better just instead of this fancy
move you can just go to 97 immediately
and then it's just all over now you do
have to capture as you will lose the
Queen if you don't rope captures now
Queen captures with Czech you have to
block and now you also lose the bishop
and you are just up a whole rook so
there's that
after Queen to b6 kostenko of course
reacted to this he played King to h8
which doesn't allow this night the e7
moved to come with check but well he
missed one a one idea now feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
well a very nice continuation for white
that Ali there's a plate here I'll give
you a couple of seconds for you to
decide if you want to do it okay for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those who just want to
enjoy the show
just Knight to the e7 it actually works
without without it even coming with
check because now black has problems
your queen is under attack the the
bishop is being pressured also it
captures on f6 is constantly hanging in
the air
so here what can you do here if you go
for something like Queen captures on d3
which makes sense I mean you do want to
attack the rook on e2 then comes ECAP
turns on f6 and now you're not in time
to capture anything for example if you
play Queen captures sorry about that if
you play Queen captures only to then
just F captures and after King captures
Queen to f6 will be a very nice
checkmate as the knight is controlling
the g8 square so not a possibility here
so after a queen d3 you would get
captures the rook cannot be captured and
there's really not all that much you can
do you cannot capture a Queen Queen will
capture on f6 and if you look to a fate
well then you just get pawn capture
screen captures and now Knight to a5
check you can move the King or you can
give up the exchange which is just you
know losing or King h8 and then just
Queen to c7 Quinta g7 is the threat of
checkmate and that there is nothing
black can do to avoid this you can you
can't move the rook or Queen captures
here if you try something like rip the
g8 then you just get the Queen if I
check row caster block again Queen g7
checkmate so a lot a lot of problems for
black so 97 definitely working Queen to
d3 was not played here here black
attempted
Queen to f7 just you know keeping the
Queen close to help out with the defense
but now just the bishop captures oh
sorry pawn captures on f6 and you cannot
recapture capturing just rook captures
the Queen is under attack
the Queen moves Knight can capture here
and then just everything falls apart
this rope is under attack Queen still
pressures this so that there's not not
much you can do here
so after this he captures on f6 with
Bishop to a eight at least maybe why
maybe black can't survive if white
doesn't have Knight captures on d5 while
grabbing a bishop but okay why jealous
continues the attack we have F captures
on g7 with Czech Queen characters on g7
and now just nice to a5 a very nice
continuation of the attack and now
everything is hanging still being
pressured rook captures rook is a threat
or a knight captures Queen is a threat
so what do you do here
here black decided to play Queen to g5
getting the Queen out of the way still
keeping an eye over the dark squares and
keeping an eye on that rook and here
white well there are a lot of good moves
but there is one move that is
particularly interesting it's a really
well the greatest move you could play in
this position so once again feel free to
pause the video here and try to you know
figure out what all the Rays are played
here I'll give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
finder of beautiful moves and for the
zoo just one injured show Queen to d4
check a very nice idea of course you
want black to capture a queen because
notice that the knight is controlling
the g7 square if rook captures rook
captures rook with check King cannot
escape due to the knight controlling g7
you have to block with the Queen rook
captures Cain captures and now yet you
just pick up the rook on d4 and white is
up a whole rook so not not possible to
capture the Queen here black tried King
to g8 but now the king is just back on
g8 so now nice the e7 can finally come
with Czech Knights the e7 check was
played now again what do you do here the
King has nowhere to go
the rook is controlling these squares
Queen is controlling these squares so
you have to capture the night you can
either capture the with the rook or with
the Queen if capture with the rook not
really something Queen will capture and
then
well whatever it plays just lost Kings
you serve and rook captures to it to
check and now you're just getting
checkmate it
you have to play something captures
captures and it's all over
so after night captures any a 97 check
black tried Queen captures 97 maybe you
know the white queen is still under
attack but it doesn't help here just
rook to rook captures on e7 was played
by fe raja and it was actually in this
position I moved 31 that a grandmaster
petrichor Stanko resigned the game
what if you resign well he's done queen
if you captured the rook then just Queen
captures rook and of course if you
capture the Queen not much better rook
captures rook first with check King
moves of course not to f7 let's say g7
and then you will pick up the bishop on
a8 as well white is up a whole look and
of course has a completely winning game
so an excellent second win in Row 4 for
Iran board for Alvarez of Raja young
Grandmaster I think is the second maybe
it's even the third I haven't checked
the you know the the previous three
games he played but definitely at least
the second win in a row and are very
important when in road for his team as
all the other three boards were drawn so
it was Ali Reza's victory over kostenko
that you know awarded Iran the victory
over Kazakhstan and before I forget I
did prepare here are the standings after
round seven there are two more rounds to
go in the Phaedo World Team Championship
so Russia's still in first place
from the beginning top three boards were
drawn today but artemyev managed to win
a nice game against via di Soria and
Karen did not play today it seems that
two two losses in a row were you know a
signal for him to take a break
England following with 11 India with 10
and it's interesting in the final round
in round 9 Russia will face India so
we're gonna have really an awesome match
perhaps the one that will decide the
winner
we have USA in fourth place China in
fifth China had a nice victory today so
they are almost you know almost there in
the top three places but not quite yet
but still two two more rounds to go it
will be interesting then with this
victory Iran climbs to sixth place then
Azerbaijan with seven cars
done 1809 and Egypt still in tenth place
with with one point yeah
there we have it like I said two more
rounds to go I do hope you enjoyed this
game and that you are enjoying my short
coverage of the feeder World Team
Championship 2019 I would like to thank
you SGC s-corporation Young carbonyl
Paul staples here tubing and the Dolores
Delano for a contribution to my channel
thank a lot I really appreciate it
I would just like to mention that
Dolores Delano is not the person who
contributed the person who contributed
was their teacher well as the story goes
he said that the children who watched my
channel
raised the 10 euros donate to my channel
as they are enjoying it and Dolores
Delano is the only girl in their in
their chess class so they wanted you
know they wanted her name to be here so
that that's quite beautiful you know
thank you very much you know if you need
anything you know they do you know
contact me I will try to you know at
least do something to repay for for your
beautiful gesture but yeah I think you
all as usual you can check - on my
previous video so you're think all for
watching and I will see you soon
well as usual some hopefully interesting
content the Capablanca saga will be
continued and for those of you who are
maybe new to the channel when we're
covering the saga that the saga is not
going anywhere couple uncas games are
there as they are we have to cover the
events that are currently being played
and then we will return to the
Capablanca saga you know it will always
be there for those of you who are you
know asking in the comments but yeah
that's that maybe maybe to finish up
with another nice photo of Sasha there
we have it thank you all and have an
excellent rest of your day